at yesterday's latinx inclusion summit
i'm not joking that was actually the
name in san antonio first lady jill
biden attempted to woo back hispanic
voters for her husband
by comparing them to tacos
but we can't get those things on our own
raul helped build this organization
with the understanding that the
diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
[Applause]
is your strength
black people
you are as effervescent as a bottle of
grape soda from the corner deli italians
you are as slimy as a bowl of scongeeli
on earth or avenue vote for us the party
of inclusion
the issue
is not that anyone is actually offended
by what joe biden said i don't think
anyone is actually offended the issue is
not that it's racist or whatever we're
all just
laughing at her and her party the issue
is that this lady and her entire party
are completely
out of touch the democrats used to be
good at pandering they were especially
good at racial pandering now they can't
even pronounce bodega what did she say
bogada what are the bogatas of the bronx
the issue is that the elite liberals are
superficial they are so removed from
people's everyday realities that they
haven't even noticed that it's going to
take more than glib references to tacos
to keep hispanic voters and the rest of
the democrat coalition in line i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from brian canary
who says only michael knowles can segue
a c s lewis quote into an express vpn ad
well done michael thank you very much
also only michael knowles can segue a
brian canary comment into an american
home shield ad right now go to ahs.com
knowles do you want peace of mind do you
want to stay on your budget that would
probably be pretty great right now while
prices on everything are going through
the roof well the one thing i promise
you you can expect this year is the
unexpected that's why american home
shield exists as a member you will know
that your budget your time and your
sanity are covered choose a plan from
american home shield keep your budget
goals in check for 2022. they offer a
choice of three great plans to help
cover the cost of repair or replace
parts of major home systems and
appliances no matter their age if
american home shield cannot repair the
covered item they will replace it ahs
members get more more coverage options
fewer exclusions we're talking hvac
systems plumbing kitchen appliances
their plans help protect parts of up to
23 essential
home systems and appliances coverage no
matter how old those systems are keep
your home up and running keep your
budget on track with american home
shield right now our listeners can take
50 off their most comprehensive plans
ever go to ahs.com knowles save 50 bucks
that's ahs.com
knowles for 50 off any plan american
home shield be sure with the shield
service fleas limitations and exclusions
apply c plan for details
the
libs
stepping on rakes when it comes to
racial identity politics is something
that i am absolutely here for i love it
if i could just watch videos of various
democrats making stupid tacos
comparisons all day i would because the
libs have benefited greatly by ginning
up racial resentment specifically racial
resentment against white people for the
past i don't know 40 50 years at least
they have gotten an electoral benefit
out of that and the electoral benefit is
starting to run out and they're they're
now
starting to have to deal with the
consequences of their own really cynical
political strategy nowhere is this
clearer than on tick tock where
a an ethnic some kind of ethnic lib
is now demanding that the white libs
keep their mouths shut
if you're a white liberal leftist or
consider yourself to be a white ally i
have a challenge for you
don't create any more content on tick
tock until september 22nd and honestly
you deserve a break because
every day is a white person day and
y'all must be exhausted so while you sit
back
listen
learn and truly decenter yourself
black indigenous and other people of
color
we got it from here please though
continue to like
comment and share our content because
y'all are always talking about how you
want to support us and create equity but
the truth that so many of y'all are
unwilling to accept is that
you do not want
black indigenous and other people of
color
to lead and pave the way because
what would we do without your
perspective your voice your commentary
your education
we would thrive
so the campaign is white libs shut up
finally a tick tock campaign i can get
behind you go girl
you tell them you tell those white lips
and white lips if you believe it if you
believe all the nonsense you've been
spouting for years then
put your money where your mouth is put
your mouth where your rhetoric is and
keep it shut keep it closed
this
an available of white racial
consciousness it's the inevitable
because what the libs have been doing
for the past half century at least it's
been encouraging every racial group in
the country to increase their racial
consciousness
for a long time in america we had been
encouraging people to decrease their
racial consciousness we say race is not
it's not the most important part of your
identity especially in a multi-racial
multi-ethnic country it's gonna things
are gonna go really bad if we all start
dramatically increasing our racial
consciousness it's going to lead to all
sorts of fighting and tension it's going
to cause a breakdown of american
democracy so i we really really
encourage people to reduce their racial
consciousness the lib said no way no way
listen black people increase your racial
consciousness listen hispanic people
same thing listen asian people even same
thing and it's worked if you look at pew
research
every racial group other than white
people has a greater than 50
racial consciousness
meaning they believe that race is very
important to their identity if you look
at black people which
that's the group with the highest racial
consciousness it's well over 70 percent
i think it's even over 75 percent but
it's certain it's certainly over 70. for
white people it's all the way down at 15
but
the white liberals have been cynically
encouraging everyone else to increase
their racial consciousness because they
think it's going to help them win
elections
it's it's natural for for groups to have
a racial consciousness by the way we we
pretend in america and in western
civilization that racism is is the
aberration that racism is the exception
in the world it's it's not that's the
natural state of man because we're
tribal beings and we naturally that
politics begins with a tribal sort of
mindset and then you can try to expand
that into the city or the state or the
nation but it begins with a really
tribal kind of identity so that's the
normal part it's normal on the left
obviously the left is chinning up this
racial stuff constantly but it's natural
on the right too and the only thing
truly the only thing
that will cut against that is
christianity the only reason that you
ever hear anyone invade against racism
or is suggest that people not have as
strong a racial consciousness is because
of christianity because christianity
says that there is neither jew nor greek
nor slave nor free but all are one in
christ jesus because christianity says
there is something much more important
to our identity namely that we are made
in the image of god and if we are made
in the image of god then there is a
solidarity among all people regardless
of their race or their origin or their
skin color or anything like that
as christianity declines in public life
you are going to see an increase in
racial consciousness on the left and on
the right
you saw it really beginning in the 20th
century on the right you know
in the far right movements like uh
nazism or which is also kind of a
left-wing modern movement but that's a
discussion for another day
but on the on the far atheist kind of
niche and right there's a racial
identity on the mainstream left there's
a huge racial identity it's only
christianity
that is putting a pause on that and as
as christianity declines as an important
part of public life if it does i hope it
doesn't decline i hope it increases
again but as it declines you're just
going to see more of that that's all
that can happen it's a really bleak
future especially for america because we
have unique racial issues in the country
but that's that's what's going to happen
and the libs are going to find
themselves hoisted on their own petards
and it's it's
sort of in funny to enjoy the
schadenfreude at the moment but
ultimately it will be really really bad
for the country now speaking of
secularization
there's uh speaking of the the decline
of christianity and public life the
church of england
which has
been a sort of farce for many decades
now some would say centuries but
certainly many decades the church of
england has now declared
that there is no
official definition of what a woman is
matt walsh's comedy movie has become
prophecy
and it describes the state of the church
of england a comments have provoked
criticism with england's first woman
priest saying she is not totally happy
with the bishop in europe's answer so
there's an irony here which is that the
church of england
for now half a century has been bragging
about how it's erased distinctions
between men and women it has women
priests it has women bishops and
priestesses i guess and bishoprises and
things like that and a lot of the
orthodox people within the church of
england left the church of england
because of that issue but now they've
erased that issue and they're saying
actually we don't know what a woman is
what is a woman we don't know nobody
knows
this is a reminder
and it's an important lesson not just
for people who are in the church of
england if you join the church of
england now i had one priest describe it
to me as not just rearranging deck
chairs on the titanic but actually
diving down and grabbing hold of the
titanic as it sinks to the bottom of the
sea
this is a reminder to anyone in any
ecclesial community any church group
people believe that that we can grow the
church by making the church more like
the world
every single time someone tries to make
the church more like the world in order
to grow the church it it doesn't do
anything but destroy the church it
shrinks fewer people show up the church
fizzles away it doesn't even resemble
much of a church anymore
do not resem people don't go to church
looking for more of the world they go to
church looking for
an alternative to worldliness
looking for salvation and a
transcendence of the world
speaking of death
not just the death of institutions but
physical death
great news coming out of virginia
because the culture of death in virginia
is being dealt a very tough blow by
glenn younkin the republican governor of
virginia here the
man i thought was a kind of moderate
republican in virginia is now pushing
for a 15-week abortion ban in what is a
very blue commonwealth
you've said you've proposed a 15-week
ban will you ever pursue
a full ban on abortion in virginia
well the reality is that as a pro-life
governor
in a state like virginia
where i have a senate that's controlled
by democrats and a house that's
controlled by republicans
we have to find a way to get things done
and i believe that's what we've been
able to do is get things done at a time
where you have to bring people together
in order to make progress
as i said i believe life begins at
conception
in virginia we've got to work with a
senate and a house
this is what we've been doing but will
you ever pursue a full ban
well i believe that what my job is is to
get something done and i believe we can
get a 15-week pain threshold build done
in virginia for the first time think
about it this was a state again that
just 18 months ago was talking about
enabling abortion all the way up through
and including birth and now we're able
to talk about a 15-week pain threshold
bill where a baby feels pain this is a
remarkable moment for us and it's an
opportunity i'm not going to let go
great answer from glenn young in here
he's not willing to take the bait and
give the democrats some big scare quote
people are going to point to this the
democrats are going to point to this and
say see he's not a moderate glenn
younkin's not a moderate he's a far
right-wing radical republican no he is a
moderate he is still a moderate
what's so amazing about this is that
the center has moved the center has
moved to the right the moderate position
on this issue has moved with the
overruling of roe v wade
this is where we always talk about
politics is downstream of culture well
this is a great example of culture being
downstream of politics this is a great
example of the law being a teacher and
shaping the culture and shaping the
democratic dialogue as well
back when roe v wade was in place
this 15-week abortion ban would have
been a radical far-right abortion ban
this would this would have been like the
mississippi law
that brought
that brought dobbs to the supreme court
in the first place
after the overruling of roe v wade
now the the
scope of the debate has broadened so
much rather than just trying to debate
okay can we ban abortion at 20 weeks or
18 weeks or 15 weeks now look there is
no constitutional right to an abortion
so now the question is do you want to
ban abortion entirely or do you want to
allow abortion entirely and glenn young
has staked out the moderate position of
a 15-week abortion ban that just two
months ago would have been a radical
far-right position this is great news
this is
largely thanks to the pro-life movement
in mississippi certainly all around the
country this is thanks to those
conservative justices this is thanks to
donald trump and other republican
presidents
who got those justices on the court and
this is thanks to the courage and
prudence of glenn yonkin
had dobbs not
not come down as it had had row not been
overruled glenn younkin would not be
able to push for a 15-week abortion ban
now he has that ability i bet glenn
young probably would
pass a total ban on abortion if he could
that's not where the commonwealth is
that's not going to work but now the
center has moved so we can do it so
let's keep pushing guys let's keep
moving that center further and further
and further because moderation is a
wonderful is a wonderful virtue we've
just got to make sure that the overton
window is such that moderation is in a
truly good
moderate virtuous place and it's not all
the way far out on the left like like
the left had shifted that window so so
far for for the past several decades now
we have to do that we have to do that
ourselves when you want to do things
yourself like fix your car you got to go
check out rock auto right now head on
over to rockauto.com write knowles in
there how did you hear about us box
so many stores these days they want to
sell you what they want to sell
they want to push products that maybe
they don't know that much about maybe
they're just the products that they're
trying to unload you know with
rockauto.com you will find exactly what
you want they are selling you the
products that you are looking for you
can look through their extremely easy to
navigate catalog you will always get the
best prices anywhere whether you're a
pro whether you're a do-it-yourselfer no
matter what time you're logging on
you're always going to get reliably low
prices no gimmicks i've told you about
my buddy my poor buddy i have to keep
making fun of him on the show because he
very stupidly went to the brick and
mortar auto parts store he goes in
asks for a part they had the part in
stock surprisingly that was good they
tried to charge him 400 bucks for it he
said wait a second michael told me about
rock auto pulls up the rock auto website
right on his phone takes two seconds
pulls up the part is 150 bucks they
wanted to charge him 400 for the part
that rock otto had for 150 bucks don't
be a fool go to rockauto.com right now
get the brakes shocks carpet wipers
headlights mirrors mufflers lug nuts and
any other part that you need be sure
when you're checking out to write
knowles in their how did you hear betis
box so they know that we sent you i'm
really impressed with glenn younkin i
think conservatives can learn a lot from
glenn younkin who is ruling
ruling with an iron fist no he's he's
governing as a conservative in a blue
state he's doing it pretty effectively
there are there are more
ways than one to skin a cat
so you can get things done through
orders from the governor's mansion you
can get things done through legislation
you get things done through the courts
and you can get get things done just by
running the bureaucrats out of power
300
virginia government bureaucrats have
quit
since may
what why have they quit in the last two
months they've quit because glenn
younkin
told them that they had to come back to
work
that was it he didn't pass some
draconian new regulation or rule he just
said okay guys you've been sitting at
home
for
two years now you have to come back to
work and 300 of them quit
employees from five different state
agencies resigned after yunkan's
new show up to work policy
and uh they a lot of them cited the
telework options and the loss of
telework options as their reason for
leaving this is really smart an
important issue that no one is talking
about zero people are talking about but
it was an important issue in the early
days of the republican party and every
so often it crops up as an important
issue is civil service reform
it that that name doesn't sound very
sexy
but what we're talking about is the
administrative state the deep state the
the
career government workers who get to
continue to govern us
whether the elected people come in or
they go or they change parties or no
matter what happens to the electeds the
the permanent governing bureaucrats
remain
and
we need to reform that system
civil service needs reform every so
often it's a long past due for reform
right now one way to reform it
make them come back to work and then
they quit their jobs and then maybe we
don't replace them or maybe we institute
some new rules as to how we hire those
bureaucrats
personnel is policy the people who are
putting your policies into place have a
lot of power over how those policies
look so you got to make sure you've got
good bureaucrats in charge you're never
going to get rid of the bureaucracy you
can trim it around the edges you can
change the way it looks but you're not
going to get rid of the bureaucracy that
is a libertarian pipe dream it's not
going to happen so you've got to make
the bureaucracy work for you this is a
very very big country i'm not just
talking about virginia here we're
talking about a country of 320 330
million people there is going to be a
bureaucracy so how are we going to make
that bureaucracy work for us we can
reform the way people are hired we can
reform the kind of power that they have
we can reform the way that they can make
rules in the agencies but we've got to
do that because that is where so much of
the government actually happens it's not
usually just the bill up on capitol hill
and i'm gonna something something
something it's not that it's not
schoolhouse rock okay it's not even just
the judges the judges have a lot of
power but most of the power is in that
bureaucracy so we've got to
got to take some lessons from glenn
younkin okay glenn young who won on
social issues by the way don't forget
that everyone's looking at glenn young
and the moderate he's the moderate
republican who's just talking about
taxes no when he was just talking about
taxes he was going to lose his race to
terry mcauliffe the democrat
he won when he started talking about
about critical race theory in schools he
won when he started talking about
transgenderism in schools and the
loudoun county rape story that actually
the daily wire broke not to shoot our
own horn but that was a major issue for
flipping that race and handing virginia
to a republican governor it was the
social issues that's where people want
moderation we don't really care that
much about marginal tax rates people
don't i like low taxes but people don't
wake up in the middle of the night
sweating because of tax rates right now
if you tell me michael the democrats
might raise your taxes and also they're
going to pump your kids full of
cross-sex hormones and chop off his
genitals so we're going to focus on the
tax issue right i'd say are you out of
your mind i don't give a damn about the
taxes compared to them transiting my kid
that's what republicans have to run on
that's where the real moderation is
there's no
the the far right wing fringe opinion
that we shouldn't
trans the kids
that is
maybe not in the minds of the media or
the minds of the lib politicians but in
the minds of voters that's a pretty
moderate reasonable position okay don't
trans the kids that's the sort of thing
we have to run on you're getting more
and more stories we predicted this years
ago we said you know there's this insane
new medical experiment going on where
we're chopping people up and mutilating
their bodies and making men look like
women and it's happening at a younger
and younger age
people in their teens even kids this is
happening too
and
you're going to see in a few years
people are going to regret this the kids
are going to say what the hell did you
people do to me
and they're going to be really angry and
they're going to go after their parents
and they're going to go after these
quack medical professionals that is
starting to happen already there's one
video in particular poor girl chloe cole
chloe is 17 years old still a kid still
a teenager
female a girl formerly thought she was a
boy started testosterone and puberty
blockers at age
13.
got her breasts chopped off at age 15 by
some quack doctor and then at 16
realized wait a second i'm not a man and
d transitioned and now
she's warning other parents do not do
this to your kids
we don't need all this insane
superficial artificial kind of stuff we
want to live in a way that's a little
more organic when you want organics you
got to check out beam organics right now
go to beamorganics.com
knowles you go to beam because i'm about
to give you a dream literally i'm going
to give you a dream did you know that a
poor night's sleep can cause weight gain
mood issues poor mental health lower
productivity some reports say that less
than six to seven hours of sleep per
night can lead to reduced white blood
cell counts white blood cells protect
our body against illness and disease
fighting viruses bacteria a whole lot
more not a lot of people realize this
but having a consistent nighttime
routine is very very important a better
tomorrow starts tonight it's why you got
to check out beam dream beam is one of
the world's most innovative functional
wellness brands with unique products for
everything from sleep to focus today our
listeners get a special discount
available for beam's sleep product dream
powder mmm their best-selling hot cocoa
contains premium ingredients triple lab
tested you wake up refreshed 98 of
people surveyed fall asleep faster when
taking beam dream 99 of people
experience a better sleep quality just
mix beam dream into hot water or milk
stir enjoy before bedtime we've got a
brand new delicious summer flavor of
dream powder sea salt caramel it's just
absolutely magnificent you can go check
it out right now if you don't love it
you get your money back guaranteed for a
limited time get up to 35 percent off
when you go to beam organics dot com
slash knowles use code knowles at
checkout b e a m organics dot com slash
knowles use codenals to check out for up
to 35 off as the world's first
non-woke streaming service
daily wire plus is everything you love
about the daily wire plus so much more
as a member you get exclusive access to
new shows and features from jordan
peterson plus the entire prageru library
including my show the book club on
prageru plus animated and live action
kids content coming soon plus original
movies and fearless documentaries that
expose deeply concealed truths such as
fouchy unmasked my documentary series
and you can watch all of this content by
going to dailywireplus.com or you can
download and open the daily wire app if
you are not yet a member you can get 35
off when you sign up now it's time to
build the future that you want to see
become a member at dailywearplus.com
today and do not forget to send in
voicemail bags for friday's episode our
voicemail bag is sponsored by puretalk i
love hearing from you so make sure you
get those in please keep them to under a
minute so i can actually play them on
the show and in the future use code
knowles know w-l-e-s
for 25 off your membership we'll be
right back with a lot more
on the one hand you've got
lunatics and freaks and perverts
in the woke activist left encouraging
you parents to trans your kids to pump
them full of chemicals get them on a
lifelong program from big pharma that's
going to be extremely expensive and
harmful to their health and chop them up
six ways from sunday
so that your little son can look more
like a daughter or vice versa that's on
the one hand on the other hand you've
got the kids who have had these medical
experiments performed on them telling
you the grisly reality of what it
actually looks like
i don't know if i'll be able to fully
carry a child
and i might be at increased risk for
certain cancers
namely cervical cancer
and because i do not have my breasts i
no longer have breasts
i
am not able to
breastfeed whatever future children i
have
that realization actually was um
one of the biggest things that lead to
me realizing
that i this was not the path that i
should have taken
you hear that pause where this girl is
just processing that
says so i i'm at increased risk of
cancer
and
people get
all sorts of medical conditions all
sorts of awful ailments because of the
the drugs that big pharma is pumping
into little kids to make them look more
like the opposite sex you get
osteoporosis all sorts of bone problems
so she says yeah i'm at an increased
risk of cancer
i might not be able to have kids i might
be totally sterile and then dawn's on he
says man and even if i can have kids
i'll never be able to breastfeed my kid
because they chopped my breasts off when
i was a little kid because
quacks and psychos and my parents and
just they all
they chopped
my perfectly healthy
organs off when i was a kid because of a
politically correct fad
because of a leftist
fantasy that they forced on me through a
medical experiment they might they might
have done it
in the sincere hope that it would help
me
that's that's the part about i'm not
saying that they're all just evil
geniuses you know
in a cauldron just trying to wreak havoc
on the world some of them are just
idiots the people pushing this stuff
some of them are just ignorant
some of them are just afraid and they're
afraid oh no the libs told me that if i
don't pump my kid full of hormones and
get them on a subscription plan to big
pharma for the rest of their lives
then my kid will kill himself oh no so i
i've really i've got to do it and i i
get it i understand that fear
and the people who have been
the people who should have known better
who are pushing this stuff should be
held criminally liable for what they're
doing to kids but just as a rule
this is not the first time
that
crazy medical experiments have been
performed on poor innocent people this
is not the last time it's happened many
times in the past it's going to happen
again
we have this
prejudice now we think we've figured out
all the medical problems in the past the
medical doctors they weren't even really
medical they were just crazy quacks
shamans witch doctors but now we know
science now back in the past people oh
my gosh can you imagine
they used to treat certain ailments with
leeches they would bleed you that's not
helpful that would kill people man you
believe those crazy guys thankfully we
have modern medical science what about
the modern medical science of lobotomies
remember when people used to put an ice
pick in people's brains and turn them
into vegetables to treat psychiatric
conditions that wasn't 300 years ago
that was what
60 70 years ago
that's that seems ins that seems like
one of the cruelest medical treatments
medical treatments quote unquote medical
experiments that's ever been done on
anybody
until this one this one might be worse
chopping off the healthy organs of
innocent little kids and making them
sterile and give them giving them
cancers and bone problems and
that i think that might be worse
actually in just permanently destroying
their bodies that might actually be
worse than the certainly than the
leeches i think it might be worse than
lobotomies
if if the past two and a half years
have taught you anything it should be
this
there is not as great a difference
between witch doctors and shamans
on the one hand and
the medical genius experts in the white
lab coats on the other as we might have
thought there was
okay in fact right now if you told me if
if i found out that i had some ailment
and i was told that i could go see one
of two people for treatment
an african tribal witch doctor with a
headdress or dr fauci
not even two seconds would it take me to
come okay all right get me my get me my
plane ticket to namibia because i sure
ain't going to nih ain't talking to the
fouch if you told me right now
let's make it even more obvious that i
i've got some medical ailment i could
either go smoke peyote in ayahuasca with
some native american shaman in the
desert and hear his medical advice or i
could be treated by dr rachel levine
get past the bowl baby get where's the
light where can i get some of that
peyote because the native american
shaman smoking dope in the desert has a
much better grasp on medical reality
then the man who thinks that he's a
woman who wears heels and a dress to the
office while he runs health for the
united states
it's not even close
and they're going to be more quacks and
weirdos in the future and that's not
going to stop and so if you're a parent
and you you've got to decide what's best
for your kid you you have to resist the
fads you have to resist the really very
credible people in authority with the
white lab coats on the stethoscope these
people have no idea what they're talking
about
if people who don't know the difference
between men and women don't know
anything
and i'm not saying that they
aren't coincidentally right about some
issues at some times
stop clock is right twice a day but they
do not have the authority that they
pretend to have
speaking of sterility and kids
there is a really really messed up story
in pink news pink news i guess is a gay
website and so this is a story i guess
that's supposed to be sympathetic to the
couple here it's a gay couple
who wanted a son
sue's ivf clinic after surrogate gives
birth to a daughter
you see this couple these two men
decided that they wanted to purchase a
baby and so they went out and they found
an egg they went through a catalog and
they picked a woman they said okay that
woman that's that's going to be the
mother of my child and they purchased
that woman's eggs and then they rented
the womb of a poor woman and then they
did all sorts of things in
rooms and medical offices and they had
doctors combine the sperm and the egg in
test tubes and then they implanted the
the little babies the the embryos into
this other woman
and very often this process involves
abortion uh very often this obviously
this process necessarily uh decouples
the procreative act from the from the
sexual act within marriage which
which just by definition can't exist
here with this gay couple and then they
said okay we want we want our baby to
look like this this this this ooh yucca
girl send him back i want a refund send
her back i want a refund
really really messed up but there are so
many problems here
on the
on the most shallow level it's sexism
this is real they're actually saying i
don't want a girl
to me a girl is less valuable than a boy
i only want a boy send the girl back
that's so there's sexism sure then on
the next level it's the homosexuals well
may you know
that's not how biology works two boys
don't get to make a baby and so when you
try to poke and prod and change
everything and manipulate nature in this
way bad things are gonna happen yep
that's true but that's not even the
deepest level
the real problem here i think
it's the clinic
the real problem is the clinic
and it's not just it's not just the
homosexuals it is the homosexuals but
it's not just the homosexuals it's not
just the sexism it's the clinic it's
it's
ultimately the big problem here is this
mistaken belief that we have a right to
a child
you don't have a right to a child
people struggle with infertility and it
can be so extremely painful sweet little
lisa and i we didn't get a baby right
away took a couple years and i know i
know i know how hard that is i know it's
really truly hard
still you don't have a right to a child
the only person who has any rights when
we are talking about procreation
is the baby and ironically maybe not
ironically
the baby's rights are the rights that we
always discard when we when we talk
about these issues in our society
ironically the only person whose rights
we completely ignore when we're talking
about procreation are the baby's rights
the baby's right to life the baby's
right to his natural mother and father
but the baby is the only person with
rights here
babies are not just a commodity to be
purchased on the free market okay babies
are a gift from god and a baby has
a natural right to his mother and father
a baby has a natural right to be
conceived in the procreative act in the
sexual act the specific conjugal act of
his parents within a marriage okay the
baby has that right
if the baby doesn't have that right
nobody has any rights in this whole
thing okay
but we've we now view babies as
commodities because we have a right to
it and therefore if we have a right to
it we have a right to do whatever we
want to do to be able to get it maybe
that involves technology maybe that
involves govern the government maybe
that involves the free market
if we have a right to a baby this couple
really hasn't done anything wrong
if a baby is a commodity to be purchased
on the free market then look this couple
they didn't get the product that they
wanted they purchased a product the the
company that produces that product the
comp this ivf company didn't give them
the product they want so you have a
right to a refund of course maybe a
30-day money-back guarantee i don't know
the problem here is that a baby is not
just a product just a commodity to be
bought and sold a baby is a human being
made in the image of likeness of god
just like you and the baby has rights
here
this this is a level the concern the
libs
i either don't get this or don't care
they just completely reject that idea
that
babies have rights and and that you
shouldn't be allowed to just force your
will on reality but
the conservatives tend to get this a
little bit more conservatives know that
this is wrong conservatives know this is
deeply deeply wrong but
can are conservatives willing to go all
the way here
are conservatives willing to say well if
you don't have a right to a baby then we
need to have a much more serious
bioethical discussion about all of these
reproductive technologies not just for
the gays not just for single women but
even for married couples maybe we need
to talk a little more seriously about
the bioethical problems with ivf
or i don't know that that a lot of
conservatives want to do that because a
lot of people have used these
technologies and have gotten kids out of
these technologies and so
it's it's easy to ignore the stories
that happen all the time you hear these
stories all the time not just with
homosexuals but you'll hear of a couple
getting the wrong baby oops there was a
mistake with the test tubes and this
couple got this other couple's baby and
now they're lawsuits and
these stories crop up pretty regularly
but if you have personally benefited
from it it's it's easy to ignore those
stories you say oh well it's not a big
deal or oh well it's the cost of doing
business right but babies are not
business they're not they're not
business it's not
we need to place limits here not just on
the government not even on on technology
on the free market you shouldn't be able
to buy and sell people
this this goes to an even deeper level
then
it's a way bigger issue and i don't know
that conservatives are totally ready to
open this can of worms the fda just
received its first application for an
over-the-counter birth control pill
this is probably a pretty bad idea by
the way because you know birth control i
mean it's just it just messes with all
of your hormones and as we're living in
a time where all these quacks are
pushing all these sorts of hormonal
treatments i'm not sure that we want to
make it easier
less regulated less oversight when it
comes to shelling these drugs
but the application came in
just weeks after the overruling of roe v
wade
and the overruling of roe v wade has
raised questions about contraceptives
so the libs because the libs can't
defend abortion or roe v wade or planned
parenthood bkc
the libs focused in and they said well
with this supreme court decision pretty
soon you're going to lose gay marriage
and the right to homosexual sodomy and
contraceptives because the principle at
play in roe v wade is the principle of
play in those cases and the majority of
the court that overruled roe v wade
specifically said no no this has nothing
to do with that it has nothing to do
with condoms or birth control or
anything like that but justice thomas in
his concurrence said yeah this decision
doesn't have to do with that but
probably it should
so thomas gave the really honest answer
here and the court is still right in
practice because well the proof of the
pudding is in the tasting clarence
thomas couldn't get a single other even
conservative judge to sign on to his
concurrence so the court is signaling
they have no appetite to overrule the
quote unquote right to contraception
but there is no right to contraception
in the constitution there is no right to
homosexual sodomy in the constitution
lawrence v texas there is no
definition of gay marriage in the
constitution where did that come no one
even suggested that you could possibly
make that argument until what 2012
2013 or something you might like
contraception
you might like homosexual sodomy you
might like
redefining marriage and you might want
to
pass laws about all those things
but it's not in the constitution it's
just completely made up and it comes
from a
substantive due process which is a an
absurd
pseudo-constitutional theory and it
comes from a general right to privacy
which doesn't exist in the constitution
and it comes from all this sort of
nonsense all the same sort of nonsense
that you see in roe v wade
so what what do we
say about this as conservatives
well
if it were me if it were i know some of
the real pro free market conservatives
they'll say
let's get that birth control over the
counter let's do it babe let's make
everything over the counter let's reduce
regulations that's a very libertarian
point of view
as a conservative i think this is a bad
i think the fda should should totally
reject this application i think it's a
terrible idea to sell birth control over
the counter i i don't think that our
nation's problem is that we need more
birth control i think the nation's big
problem is we don't have enough babies
america
for the past 50 years has had a below
replacement birth rate the country is
literally dying and now the libs want to
make
hormone birth control pills even easier
to get your hands on without regulation
probably much younger people would be
able to do it without parental
notification it's a crazy idea it's a
really bad idea the
in fact the entire birth control regime
is pretty recent it comes from griswold
v connecticut that was a case decided in
1965 which said that married couples
have the right to birth control pills
and condoms and stuff like that and then
a case seven years later eisenstad
versus baird uh 1972 which says that
unmarried couples have a right to
contraceptives as well so this is very
very recent these were cases decided
almost at exactly the same time as roe v
wade with almost the exact same stupid
meanings at almost exactly the same part
where our culture really began to careen
off of the cliff now what some
conservatives will say is well hold on
if you don't want abortion
actually it's mostly liberals who make
this argument they'll say if you don't
want abortion then we need to have
contraception
between the two it's much better to have
contraception than abortion uh okay why
don't we have neither
or why i'm not even saying i'm not
pushing for a nationwide ban on birth
control or something like that though i
do think if people want to ban birth
control they want to go to their elected
representatives and ban it totally fine
by me sounds great
we we need more babies and we have too
much of a culture of contraception
absolutely
but why are those the alternatives what
if we just what if we do
what we did in this country until
1972
and say well you can
either abstain from sex
or you can get married and have kids
and have a good life what if we do that
what people will say then is well in the
modern hookup culture that's just so
unrealistic
where do you think we got the modern
hookup culture from
where do you think that did that just
fall out of the sky
is that is that just politics is
downstream of culture no that's an
that's some evidence that culture
frequently is downstream of politics you
get the modern hookup culture
it one sure the these legal decisions
can be influenced by cultural changes
but the legal decisions influence
cultural changes as well and a culture
that enshrines abortion as some right in
a culture that enshrines contraception
of some sacred right and pushes it
everywhere is going to get more of those
things
this is what the libs have been
complaining about after the dobbs
decision you had all these new stories
in the washington post and the new york
times and elsewhere
talking to people who said you know i
think i might start abstaining from sex
i might start being a little more
careful about my sexual partners because
now i can't kill my child so i might
have a baby and and that means i'm going
to have to be a little more thoughtful
and then the conservatives all said
uh-huh
cool sounds great
are the conservatives really willing to
go all the way there are they really
willing to have that conversation
because
very often it feels like what
conservatives want to do is just roll
back the crazy radical cultural changes
about
six years
we just want to go back to the halcyon
days of
2015 or so i don't
not quite
we do but of course if you
if you only return to the cultural and
political circumstances of the recent
past you're very likely going to end up
in exactly the same place we are now
we have to address root causes why is
our country literally dying
you're going to have to look back at
some changes that took place 50 60 years
ago to figure that out
how did we get to the part the spot
where we're mutilating our little kids
because of political correctness how do
we get to the spot where we're killing
850 000 babies a year how do we get to
the spot where where a homosexual couple
is basically complaining about how they
want to return their baby because they
got a little girl instead of a little
boy at the baby store
we got to go back a little bit further
than just the past few months or years
another question another big question on
this and some democrats are starting to
ask this if roe v wade is so important
if abortion is so sacred to the
democrats why didn't they codify it into
law when they had the chance for 49
years of roe v wade being the law of the
land kamala harris gives a typically
eloquent answer
when you look back did democrats fail
past democratic presidents congressional
leaders to not codify
roe v wade over the past five decades
i think that to be very honest with you
i i do believe that we
should have rightly believed but we
certainly believe that certain issues
are just settled
certain issues are just settled clearly
we're not no that's right and that's why
i do believe that we are living sadly in
um real unsettled
times
certain issues are settled and when you
unset all the issues they're not they're
no longer settled and so we should have
settled them a long time ago sure okay
in as much as kamala i actually kind of
want to defend kamala harris here in as
much as she said anything
she is right
the libs didn't codify roe v weighed
into law because they didn't think they
needed to
because they control everything and yeah
maybe sometimes conservatives get a
slight majority on the supreme court for
a few cases and yeah maybe they win the
presidency but they don't have the
executive agencies and yeah maybe they
win the house or something but it
doesn't matt the libs control every
institution so they felt they didn't
need to
and they still probably don't i mean
even this major decision that that
overrules roe v wade abortion is still
legal almost everywhere and
the pro-abortion side is still the major
side in um the american power structure
it's we're not living in a world in
which abortion has been made illegal
we've just given a little place for for
people to pass pro-life laws if they
want
now
speaking of speaking of settling things
down uh rage against the machine has
gone viral you remember them they were
banned from like 25 30 years ago rage
against the machine has gone viral
because they're so angry about the
supreme court decision that they they
want to abort the supreme court
you see they've got in their stages it's
forced birth
in a country that's the only country in
the world without guaranteed paid
parental leave at the national level
they have to add all those words because
we do have lots of maternity and even
paternity leave these days forced birth
in a country
where black birth givers they won't say
women they say birth givers experience
maternal mortality at a higher rate
and where gun violence is so bad since
something completely unrelated this
forced birth in a country with gun
violence
abort the supreme court
yeah abort them you you tell them guys
regardless of the politics of rage
against the machine this is the most
i've ever listened to reggie against the
machine and i can never get those 55
seconds back and i regret that i regret
that and now you've got to experience
that with me too regardless of their
politics
this music is just
unbearably awful it's just so
so bad
but i had to play it for you because the
whole thing shows you
who's really on the side of the machine
here
who's really forget about okay you get
five judges on the supreme court for one
case okay now and they're losing their
minds over this
who's on the side of the machine
when it comes to
abortion
when it comes to
the sexual revolution when it comes to
racial politics when it comes to
immigration when it comes to every
single issue
rage against the machine these
multi-multi-millionaire rock
stars they are
saying the things
that the ruling class says they are
pushing the ideas the ruling class
pushes
they are raging for the machine blm
rages for the machine they go out they
rage they burn the country down but
they're raging for the machine all of
the power structures support them and
they bail them out of jail when they get
arrested and go to jail that's
that is the side of the machine i think
people are waking up to this i think the
the pandering has become much more
transparent i i think it's going to take
a whole lot more than taco comparisons
to keep that coalition together
especially as the machine becomes so
much more destructive i'm michael
knowles this the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show almost
two-thirds of democratic voters say they
don't want joe biden to run for
president again joe biden is now calling
latino people tacos and democrats don't
have any 2024 bench that's today on the
bench bureau shall give it a listen